so I want to introduce a new Turman
series that you maybe haven't heard of
yet this is called the Armageddon
championship series and it's being held
on chessarena.com this is a playing
platform that's supported by fide and
World Chess and for this tournament
series there's a whopping 460
000 Euro prize fund and it's a pretty
elaborate structure of events it starts
with the online Regional cups and the
way this works is anyone can play up to
three regional cups in their division
and if you finish in the top 20 in any
of the regional cups then you move on to
the online finals which will be in
January 2023 and if you do well in the
online finals then you make it to the
OTB events in Berlin where then there's
even more prize money up for grabs so
let me show the schedule of the online
Regional cups it does vary based on
which division you choose to play for I
know people watching this content are
probably scattered across the world so
if you're in Europe or Africa or Asia
Oceana and hopefully there's times where
you'll be available to play
now I do want to note that it does cost
a little bit to join you do need to pay
for a pro membership which is usually 25
Euros I will leave a link in the
description and you can use coupon code
Rosen to save 10 and get access to play
in this amazing tournament series and
each of the online Regional Cups has a
prize fund of 1 000 Euros and then the
online finals for each division has a
prize fund of 10 000 Euros
so you're about to watch the first
online Regional cup that I played in for
the Americas Division and this
tournament attracted some really strong
players over the course of 11 games I
played Grand Masters Andrew tang and
George Meyer Jose Martinez al-shon Moore
diabadi and you should watch until the
end to see if I managed to win any prize
money uh prizes are awarded to the top
10 finishers of each Regional cup and
one more thing to note is the first two
games I played my opponents didn't show
up they just lost by four of it so the
video will start with my round three
game uh normally it's it's 11 games
total I ended up playing nine games
total got a couple free points in the
beginning so I do hope you enjoy the
content and big thank you to the
Armageddon series for sponsoring this
video now stay tuned for the next one
that I will likely play on November 12th
I will likely live stream it on my
twitch channel so looking forward to
seeing you there and now let's get to
the chess
hey okay we have a game
it's lasting longer than one ply
um a Dutch is something that
I can play against
yeah this is this is my main propaganda
Dutch
as early C5 move it's to activate the
lights for Bishop
um I think Queen B3
generally it's it's fine if black plays
D5
I mean it's a more closed position now
but it's very pleasant structure
ensuring my dark squared Bishop Will
Survive
not entirely sure which way I want to
Castle
[Music]
um maybe King side
foreign
there
and the E5 would have allowed the Knight
T2 Fork
I think Queen C2 is useful so there's
many cases where I want to play like B4
B5
and uh yeah the queen already served its
purpose on B3
yeah there's actually a big difference
between
our setups okay g5's coming can't really
stop it
I was gonna say that like I have an
outpost on E5 but
the knight in E4 is not an outpost
because of F3
[Music]
now I think with Pawn or queen
I'll take with pong
and C4 later I opened the B file as well
[Music]
um
yeah Bishop takes E5 I take back with my
Bishop
and some G4 idea
G4 would be crazy like this is a
situation where
I think both players probably want to
attack on the king side
but for now it looks like my setup is
just more preferable
and G4 super aggressive move
um
a hard position to crack
like King H1
idea Rook G1
and Knight G7 is a good move
I have a cool idea to take and Bishop D6
and F4
now my Bishop's just in box territory
and the plan is to double up on the G
file maybe even triple up
like put the Rook on G3 other Rook to G1
and queen to G2
okay so Queen H4 might be coming
H4 King H2
like gradually preparing the
G file battery
a pleasant position
it's actually the problem of like the
Stonewall setup
for black is uh especially the light
Square Bishop
it doesn't really have a great purpose
um I don't really want to trade darks
for Bishops but I have to
it's still really Pleasant like the the
prospect of tripling up
and then eventually taking on F5
should be good enough
although black is going to double up
behind the G Pawn
or not
okay so let's take
and now yeah here's a triple up this is
what I was talking about a while ago
and uh
it's not quite over but it's almost over
this movie Rook G6
I'm threatening Maiden two
yeah maybe then two
okay
black resign
okay that was a nice game
hope people enjoyed that one
I tried removing Queen G6 in the end
um yeah pre-moves are possible
the multi-free moves like that's on
chess.com aren't possible but
I wouldn't use that so often anyway
so if we go back to tournaments
hey okay I'm three out of three okay
yeah it seems like um there is some
issue given that my first two opponents
didn't show up
yeah let's hold off on predictions for
this tournament this is my first time
playing in it I'd rather just
focus on playing the games
uh let me hide chats
and here oh I'm playing Renato Terry
okay
so we're tied for first we both have
three points
um we've played on chefs.com a bunch of
times before
I'm trying to remember like I think he's
also a London player
no that's minlay does he play
I forget his openings
do you play E4
can't even remember if he plays E4 D4 he
might mix things up though
okay
London
we might see London
no Queen's Gambit
oh uh play Asics
okay we'll play one of these
so this idea of Queen E7
um start with Queen E7 eventually like
Bishop A3
never mind
C5
and C5 looks okay
very kind of symmetrical like structure
Queen C2 I have to play H6
and probably Bishop takes
so B4 I always have to be careful about
[Music]
um
I think everything is reasonably under
control
although there's B4 E4 wait B4 E4
I might be close to losing a piece
I'm losing a piece
that's insane if I'm losing a piece
yeah the problem is Bishop D6 E4 my
vision moves and then E5
I might just be losing a piece here
that's crazy
can I take
hmm
that's some weird trap
like I don't see how they got out of it
either
like I want to create tricks but
Queen D7 takes takes
I play Queen D7
takes takes takes
I'm just losing
I mean I could take on taking on beef
taking B4 doesn't work either Bishop A3
that's so crazy then just like losing
material here
oh what to do
I'm I saw this line and I might as well
go for it there's some pressure against
each two
I doubt this works at all though
a good move
like the dream is to check me on each
two
but it's a very far-off dream
uh oh
that's not good I have to play this
otherwise Knight G5
yeah
oh I'm getting crushed this game I fell
for I don't know if that was an opening
trap or just some middle game tactic
I'm trying to resist a little bit
[Music]
I can't really drop the knight in the
end
takes takes
uh what do I do
I could probably just resign at this
point but
I'd like to create some chances I'll
play Rook
Rook C8
some idea of taking it on B4
I'm just down a full minor piece
especially for a great move
five
I don't even know what I'm hoping for
I am down I'm down well over a minute
I guess I'm hoping my opponent just
thinks and gets careless and gives me
some chance to come back
oh no
the potential
we do have Officer Clark Bishops
which is a feature
like it basically makes it so I have an
ounce of Hope
maybe six is coming though
oh dear
I play G5
I don't know what I'm doing
maybe I'll double up behind the a pawn
go for roques
or maybe go for A4
what if I take
I'm Rook 83
.
um
oh no my Pawn
oh no my Rook
okay
uh where's the resign button
I don't actually see the resign button
or
Zen
I mean I'll play on because
that's a different way to lose
okay good game
okay so I'm three out of four
a few perfect scores
I mean I could be playing another strong
player next game
okay next game starting soon
playing Cesar
Ugarte
here we go
Mainline London
yeah Knight E5 is maybe not the type of
move most players are used to
ah what's the line like King E7 takes in
C4
I think I'm supposed to take on on C5
and C5 was kind of a mistake there from
Black
because of the sign
and black essentially loses causing
rights
one of the main traps in this position
okay I'm allowing Queen B6
I'm just assuming it's it's fine for me
maybe I should have taken a little bit
more time there
but yeah this should be fine
so I want to play C4
I think C4 is okay
in the event of the night trade then the
d-pong would be pinned to the queen
and essentially I'm trying to open the
center
especially with Black's King on f8
because it's just hard to get the Rook
into the game and now the Center opens
up then
you know it's much easier for me to
connect my Rooks
do I have 92
hmm it's a little bit tricky still
like if I take
Bishop B3
Bishop B3 is a safe move
I think it keeps some small advantage
oh snap what did I do
okay
I'll snap
that happens like once every maybe four
or five months
on various websites used to happen to me
more on YouTube for some reason
something might be off with my like
computer memory
okay thankfully I did not forfeit the
game
uh Queen E2
I'm happy to avoid the queen training
although yeah black had some counter
Play Bishop G3
wow H5
play H4
then G G5 I don't think G5 is a huge
concern
maybe just H3
it's a little bit unsettling though
what was that
something just beeped
or chirped
okay I want to play Bishop 4 probably
okay
let's defend
yes something was gone a little bit
wrong
I think it's still okay for me though
I would just want to trade on e4
probably taking time here
I mean Pawn or queen takes are probably
both acceptable moves
foreign
useful kind of resolving the pin and
next move I'll probably move the Rook
expecting Queen G6 as Queen E5 may be
possible
uh Queen C7
um
I don't think it's so bad Rook C2 Queen
D3
I'll be threatening Queen d8
wow or D5
let's start with A3
foreign
[Music]
I don't want to draw though
ticks
I should have played Knight C3 sooner
[Music]
um
that was a question if I go for a draw
or try and win
I mean King F2 F5 loses
[Music]
ah okay that was a draw for earlier
I mean do I wanna fight for a win Maybe
let's fight for a win
it's risky like I'm accepting a much
worse position
do we repeat I don't think we repeated
oh there's a resign button there's a
draw button okay
okay
only taking time
I'm trying to use the clock as a weapon
Queen trade I have to accept it
um
and there's some counter play
I hope
[Music]
um
let's play this
I mean I'm kind of relying on my speed
I think I'll be faster in the time
scramble like the ending might still be
like closer to drawing
I am down the pond but okay there's some
G6 potential
G6 is easy to miss too
yeah I think I'll start with G6
the idea is to play Rook F7
and now I'm threatening mate it's kind
of like a windmill
and then I take this now I'm not even
down material
and The Rook was very well placed there
uh let's define ah
okay let's play this move
okay the risk paid off
opponent played well like especially out
of the opening
like nice idea this H5 H4 and activating
The Rook with Rook H5
but I escaped I'm four out of five I
think
and here we go
oh I'm playing Andrew's next game okay
good luck to Andrew
found out about this tournament uh I
think through this stream
wow I haven't played Andrew in a while
I mean we played a bunch on I mean
unleash us I think someone chess.com
[Music]
I know he's a London player he's also
like Queen's Pawn opening player
if he plays London I mean he knows all
the London tricks and drops
this will be interesting
yeah London time
ah this line okay so he's playing Joe
Bava London which I don't think I've
ever actually played this line against
him before
yeah there's F3 Bishop E2 Knight F3
okay Knight B5 is not supposed to be
good there but why
it's supposed to just take
oh Knight B5 is the main line actually
forgot about this prepare this for Levy
a while ago
yeah this is actually a solid line maybe
for both sides
white has a bishop hair but I have easy
development
um is he gonna play Queen A4
let's play Vision D6
and queen E4 Queen C7
and pleasant opening
I want to go for minority attack like B5
B4
maybe uh E5 as well
should at least be on my radar
we might see Bishop G5
or that move
[Music]
and G6 looks a little bit too weakening
but
is maybe the way to go
I'll play G6
there's a bishop G3 check
starting with this
so if takes I think I take back with
Ethan just to enable the queen to defend
and he forces move
E5
that's the common principle to like
respond
you should respond in the center when
the opponent's attacking on the flank
oh that's a good move
I mean do I have the E4 it takes takes
takes
I could throw in B3
looking at Knight E4 as well
crazy position here
[Music]
um
this looks so risky
I'm allowing the sack
calculation was Queen
uh
let's try it
Bob at the bishop hangs
yeah that's not good
ah what to do
there's a funny line
that's probably not so funny though
let's try it
yeah what a crazy position
okay this is kind of a funny line
I'm scared of Rook
wait how does this work okay oh when I
queen I defend H7 actually so there's a
funny line rookiech one B1 queen queen
E6 queen of seven rookie King G7 Rook H7
would be mate
but uh the queen defends from B1
oh but I don't defend against Queen H6
go
oh like a game
yeah I I had seen I'd cover each seven
but not H6 well played
there's a question why not Knight G7 let
me download the PGN
uh bear with me one moment can I open
this
I'm going to open this in a different
tab
yeah there's a question why not a G7
um I didn't calculated this fully but I
assume Queen H7
and then here here
it's not pretty
F6 and some Bishop G5 idea
yeah many ways to win for whites I mean
earlier maybe the position was okay
so it got really tricky
yeah earlier maybe I should go for E5
good game though
okay so I'm four out of six
still top ten oh if I finish top 10 it's
guaranteed at least 25 Euros
so I'm still barely in the top 10.
okay next game playing Miguel Medina
pause
oh this is an I am ah okay so we see the
title here
if I click
here's my opponents
from the US okay
foreign
here we go
I recently learned that this uh this
variation is called the barman variation
and I think I'm gonna go for a Cambridge
Springs
I've been studying this opening a lot
more recently
I'm actually planning to make a chess
course
like about Cambridge Springs and just a
whole rapper targets D4
um
we're going into a line that I was
recently
uh just learning on my own but preparing
to show in this course to
um Bishop you choose a playable move but
it does allow this
I mean we basically now have a reverse
French structure
I played Timor grave the other day in a
bullet game he also played Bishop E2
okay so Bishop E7 looks natural
I didn't want to concede the bishop here
Larkspur Bishop is usually Black's good
Bishop too with uh
so many pawns on light squares
uh there's A6
realizing the bishop might be better on
D6
and rookie eight maybe rookie eight I
don't know Knight b5's coming
to play A6 first preventing Knight B5
yeah B4 Queen d8 it might be a little
bit passive it's weird to like be
passive while also having more space
just realized C7 is still a Target
I want to play Knight f8 soon
Queen B6 94
[Music]
yeah this actually might be really bad
for me I guess I have this move
in Quincy there's 94 Bishop G7 but now I
have this move
Queen is finding some new purpose
on the king side
okay
of Harley Queen maneuvering
I mean this is natural
maybe some G5 idea coming
I think the queen would be happiest on
G6
to align with the King
ah there's Bishop C7
I mean what else to do
ah there's an interesting idea though
probably doesn't work
I'm going to lose exchange but there's
still some attacking chances
I was thinking Rook CA could be
interesting but after it takes takes
Queen B3
there's no more pin
so I'd much rather have the bishop leave
the board than the knights
Bishop C6
so I'm down the exchange but this is
still far from over
now I have an idea to play H4
maybe not too soon
I'll just start maybe bishop here first
there actually might be a lot of
compensation here
long term I want to play Bishop B6 Queen
D6
wow
at work
that wins upon
a
night
thank you
a crazy idea
[Music]
okay
okay let's go for the crazy idea
for the Knight of seven or Knight F2
this could backfire but basically going
all in
sacrifice everything it might be
checkmate
ah there's rickoff no Rook have four of
the there's a pin on the third ring
potentially
oh this is really crazy
[Music]
so workout for I take and the epon's
pain to the queen
the king can't run
hopefully I can't hide either
and I'm threatening Queen H2 checkmates
am I just winning now might just be
winning
because yeah Rook out four is basically
the only move to prolong the game
I'm pretty sure I had to be worse there
opponent resigns wow
okay I turned around
let me download this game
yeah this actually isn't chew um
too cumbersome to like just download the
game for analysis
um I do want to check though Bishop E2
so this position
okay I'm not going to leak all my course
files right now but this position I've
been like looking at more closely
recently
we'll just use my local stockfish
engine does give a plus but after Bishop
E2
oh Bishop B2 is bad for white because of
ed4
oh
okay Switching to one CPU
takes takes
and then oh it takes on The Bishop's
attacks oh wow
Bishop H4 B5
ah so
if one wants to keep the bishop black
holds onto the pawn otherwise box just
got suspicious pair
okay that's good to know
the bishop E2 I've I've noticed like
strong players are inclined to play this
move
it scores well for white too but it
shouldn't be a great move
okay learned a small lesson there
oh should I maybe I should look at the
I should look at
what was happening towards the end
like was the sacrifice even sound
I played Bishop C6
let me disconnect
the board isn't too small
yeah white was winning then white was
very winning yeah Knight D5 just had to
break down the center
but after Bishop E2
[Music]
then black is winning because of what
happened in the game
okay
okay back to tournaments
we just finished round seven
four more rounds to go
oh I'm playing elshon oh elshon recently
played this um
uh us championship
okay
and he's probably warmed up he's been
playing a lot of Chess recently
I played Alshon once uh OTB in Chicago
open
we had like a super long game
that ended with me having to defend King
and Knight versus King and Rook
but I remember that game because he fell
into some like opening trick in the
London
so
I'm gonna play at London
and we'll see how prepared he is
I don't think he he definitely didn't
have any londons during us Champs
I don't think that London was played
during U.S Champs
C6 oh he wants to play Carol Khan
uh okay
London versus slav or this line
wait E4 is already possible
wait a minute it's a line here
no neither three first yeah this is this
is still prop
it took me a moment to remember
I'm fine going into this
I'm down the pond but uh
E5 already Queen
considering E5
E5 is like a very direct move
but it's to try and take advantage of
the fact I'm fully developed
now c4
I have all my minor pieces developed
that only has a queen developed
so it requires playing in a certain
style wow Bishop H6
so black just wants to trade
I think a C5 has any merits
five Queen
and there's not too many options here
actually
maybe you like Rook B1 first
I don't want to move too slowly
hit
that's crazy that he can like get away
with us
okay so now 905 I take and when B7
turkey one
I really want to play E6
and Rook B3
ideas to not trade off
still down the pawn
there's compensation the bigger factor
is time
yeah some H3 move
C5 coming
G4 might be coming
hmm
Bishop E6
Queen C1
I mean eventually Queen C1
thank you
this would be two I play Queen D2
he's still Queen D2
[Music]
how to do this
[Music]
um
okay so I want to take on the five Queen
H6 and AG 5.87 checkmate
at least I have a plan now
I mean there is an H4
really so if I take
let's go for this
it looks super risky for luck
he does have rookie eight
I have E6 as well
it takes
requires more positional play I think
assorted
I'm gonna play Rook D6
time is my biggest concern I like the
position though
this is a fork
hitting H7 and The Rook
I mean he might take on G5
here I can take
yeah Rook CA coming
ensuring there's no Queen invasion
well there's one check
okay
that was a nice game that was uh it
started with like a very offbeat London
line
that um
I mean in my London course I I do have
like one video covering this line
on uh
the specific Gambit sacking the B2 Pawn
going for the center I think E5 is the
most principled move here too
oh dear
okay I
ah the chess base just crashed
oh I'd love to like share some more
details in that game
but uh
chess face is dead
so what to do
oh Andrew Chang has also lost two oh so
I'm basically tied with Andrew if he
if he manages to win in second place in
second place
oh I'm playing jossman okay
okay minimizing chat again
Jasmine I should really know Jasmine's
openings I think he plays he's using the
E4 and G4 player
I mean he's super super strong and
online looks and bullets yeah his score
against me is probably like 80 to 90
percent
so there's no pressure
nothing to lose here just want to play a
good game
and yeah he just had like a really crazy
game too
I'll play one of these
ah the sign
okay we'll play some Dragon setup
I should know what I'm doing here
some E5 move at some point
in Knight C6 first
this might be the wrong approach but it
looks interesting
idea later to play E6
that's a fairy move
okay so the light wants to go to D6 I
mean this is a typical maneuver
for the structure to just blockade the
pollen with a knight
and now there's F5 ideas
also Bishop A6 ideas
hmm
[Music]
um
I mean queen H4
and Bishop D7 first
I'm thinking like rook ae8 and then F5
if white plays off four I think I force
a draw
okay effort might be coming but
it's risky for lights
F5 is coming for me
Bishop F2 the queen can retreat
it seems like a stable position
[Music]
A3 okay
I got seven I mean b4's idea
thank you
I mean do I have Bishop H6
Bishop have two they're there
a crazy line
let's go for it
so Bishop F2 Bishop F4 I think
and then G3 fe4 gf4 Queen H3 King G1
oven ef3 in the end
but now there's tension
I could take the bishop
I think that makes sense to actually
just take an F4
I'll get the pawns rolling
like G5 H5
I think it's some accomplishment to
trade off the dark side Bishops
foreign
both sides of the board
and gradually prepare G4
that wants to be somewhere else maybe
and it's still good on
current Square
28
might shift around a bit here
fighting A4
that's my plan
okay I want to play I have a plan now is
A6 B5 B4
the Queen's arms Queen side pawns
rolling
uh
okay Queen is seven
hmm
I should probably break with G4 at some
point oh e5's hanging
okay I can defend
Queen's tied down to the ninth
I don't know why I left E5 hanging
maybe my king should be on F6
um
might be seven ideas
finding Queen E5
Rook B1 Knight C5
idea Knight B3
is very tricky
really
there goes my knight
that's annoying
foreign
oh no
no
no my time now what to do
uh almost uh
almost a silly trap I mean
oh it was such a nice position to I was
in control of the whole game but he just
kept surviving and there were some
tricks like it got crazy towards the end
of the two
well played
that had to be one of the last games too
I think oh I'm playing York Meyer
okay this is not quite the last round
this is a penultimate round
wow
okay
uh I played gorg Meyer I had a lot of
times before
I know he likes to play the French
ah yeah we played this line a bunch of
times before
I played this move
let's try it
I'm mixing things up a little bit
so it basically provokes either D5 or
Knight C6
both moves arguably are a little bit
annoying for black to play
I think H4
that should be a little bit careful here
like how to do this
and this first
H5
I don't think uh Knight B4 works
the same thing with Knight D4 it's
Knight D4 Queen B7 Knight C2 King D1
Knight A1
I think the Knight gets trapped this is
a crazy line
and the end I have Bishop C7 now
57 Queen C8 Bishop A6 and
I'll win The Rook
and then hopefully throughout the nights
the reason for playing h4h5 is to play
Queen G3
and not not have to worry about Knight
H5
and queen G3 actually will threaten G7
and C7
so it's a fancy way of playing
up a lot of time
and take Rook G8
something I want to take immediately
I'm just a knight of three first
foreign
the problem is Knight D5 happens in some
lines
I'm actually thinking about E4 here
before trade trade E4 take
E4 E5
maybe bishop E3 there
on trade
okay I think if if E5 I just take once
G6 is a good move
yeah because Knight H5 is coming and
it's kind of hard to stop
I could play H6 and then sack
I could just play H6 and not sack
Queen H2 of Knight H5
it's still up a little bit of time
yeah I was thinking I'd take once and
play Bishop E3
P3 immediately
there should be three immediately
actually looks nicer
that way I don't open the G file
and if Taylor wasn't at H5 like in
between move
okay so this D5 is some idea
D5 is probably the principal approach if
I'm allowed to do it
that's a move
like
hmm that's actually kind of annoying
like Bishop D3
hmm
I think Bishop D3 like it's a safe move
the problem is
I guess tech6 Queen B5 I have Knight C4
might be conceding the bishop hair
wow funny position
A3
am I gonna get the center Pawn Cube
no I'm not
oh F5 is a good move
if I take first take take
hmm
I want to take an open the center though
Bishop G5 take take
very scary position
moving too slowly
I'm going for the crazier line
Queen D3
maybe just castling or something
Queen G7
[Music]
um
this is slightly terrifying
I'm down on time I want to play Rook C3
in Castle
oh that's a good move
that's a really good move
a king D1
draw
how am I still alive
still alive kind of
that's not good though
sign
so little time down like a minute
foreign
[Music]
seven seconds
okay
rookie seven coming
I refuse to flag
dope
another 0.1 seconds left there
or zero seconds left
oh that was rough
oh thank you joking for the sub
uh
[Music]
uh
I don't know how much time there will be
to analyze I think I'm out of the top
ten oh next seems starting I'm in 11th
place so I need to win this game
to have a chance of winning 25 Euros
should I enable auto Queen
Auto Queen okay done
I'll open the Naples
hopefully save me a Split Second
okay here we go
the final game
and played a lot of strong players so
far oh I'm actually playing an FM
almost didn't see the title
Arturo Augusto
London opening time
there we go
still Theory
Queen E7
it's a little bit strange
let me do this move first usually Queen
C7 is played
I'm not actually sure of the purpose of
Queen E7
looks like a fine move but
maybe 97's coming
[Music]
uh no draw
okay I'm already threatening some Bishop
H7 ideas
not sure if they work but like there's a
fun line to fantasize about
is F6 Bishop B17 King H7 Knight G5
it would be a double piece stack fg5 hg5
King G8 Queen H5
Bishop E5 it could actually be a triple
P sack where like after episode V5 I
don't take
like I'd talk most of my minor pieces
component doesn't let me have so much
fun
um so probably here
it makes sense to start trading a little
bit
not sure the best approach though
like maybe this and then some Queen A4
not sure if I want a castle
decision can come later
so Queen A4 has some idea of Queen A3
eventually
to then pin along the diagonal
also hit C6 which is nice
foreign
yeah something like
um
not sure how to make this work
five
which is like Rook T1 first
I mean is E5 coming though
if I might be coming
[Music]
and this first
I wasn't sure what to do there
I can't be moving too slowly
yeah so rookie now I can take
maybe Knight
I'm taking 95
maybe C4 at some point too
or D1 I don't know
just gotta move quickly
I want to keep my Rook on H1 to support
H Pawn
I might throw an H5 H6
may be coming
okay
it's so weird like to try and resolve
this pin or try and like add more
pressure
okay let's take C4
and 95 takes takes
takes
let's play H6 first
like long term if Alpha zero has taught
me anything
plan on H6 can be good long term
and now 95
The Rook might just stay on each file
like if it wants to activate maybe Rook
H4 later
announce the question does block hold on
to z-pong or trade
holds on to the C Pawn so I have F4 here
to play Rook D2
ah interesting
don't think I want to trade Queens
although maybe I have to
I don't think I have to
it's risky though
Rook B6 I'm thinking Rook H3
oh that's a great move
I might be in some trouble
King F2 Maybe
a very tense position
[Music]
Queen
B6 coming I was thinking G4 could come
between each one
this is annoying
king of three first
this seems a little bit self-destructive
it's interesting though
idea queen of six
yeah this is worse for weight
although black has a lot of Pawns these
pawns it's like a social distance Pawn
Cube
E4 is going to fall and then
subsequently all the other pawns are
gonna fall hopefully
oh wow what is this
take take
temporarily down the pawn but that's it
I'm winning upon by force
okay
um so it's equal material
my muffin time
I could even like try and play for a win
okay
yeah
this is exactly my way
this could be upon race
let's go okay well the game
oh yeah turning down the draw offer
really it's a good decision
ah I'm cold
had my fan like going uh the whole time
didn't have times I reached and turn it
off
okay I think that's the last game of the
tournament
uh if we go back that was around 11 out
of 11.
and my certificate
hey I got the certificate
of virtual certificates
hey seventh place that means I win money
I think
out of 97 players
here we see the final standings
wow good job Jose Martinez
finishing in clear first
and winning 500 euros
yeah big thanks to chessarina.com World
Chess and fide
or uh making this event possible and
also for sponsoring the Stream
um for those interested in playing in
future events
uh we do have the commands of join
command
the Armageddon command oh Armageddon
command will link you to this page with
all information
[Music]